okay so let's jump into the thick of it
what can we measure in a simulation a
quick recap from the last lecture this
is going to be just a few minutes so
first radiant flux this is the total
amount of energy passing through a
surface per second what does it mean I
imagine some shape anywhere in this
space and I count the amount of energy
that is passing through this shape every
second what is the unit of it it's what
or Joule per second this is this and
this is apparently not enough this is
not descriptive enough to create light
simulations and please raise your hand
if you know why okay well let's take a
look so this has that amount of energy
passing through a surface measured per
second so when we measure the high
radiant flux value somewhere we don't
know if we have measured a lot of energy
that passes through a small surface or
if we have drawn or imagine the large
surface and there is just a bit of
energy passage so this is the same
amount of radiant flux so this metric is
ambiguous it's it's not good enough and
this is just an image to to imagine what
is really happening so what is the
solution for the time being let's
compute the flux per unit area this we
call irradiance and this unit area means
that we don't imagine any
shape we imagine something that is one
square meter so we learned by square
meters so I have explicitly said that
it's going to be this big and whatever
is going through this this is what I'm
interested in okay well unfortunately
this is still ambiguous and the reason
for this is that we haven't taken into
consideration what angle the light comes
in and you will hear about this in a
second so it matters whether you get a
lot of energy in a big angle or a small
amount of energy in a small angle this
is this is ambiguous so let's grab it it
is spy
also norming with the angles so we are
talking about unit Atticus so this
meters the square meters we also divide
by stay radians well what does it mean
so stir idioms is basically angle in
multiple dimensions because in in the
textbook tastes only one angle to take
into consideration if you draw a
triangle but if you would like to look
at for instance you it matters that I
turn my head to the right direction in
this direction but if I would be looking
here I wouldn't be seeing you so I need
to take care of another direction so
this is what we need to notify still
radians so multiple directions next
question is so this was radians
what's normed by square meters normed
biased radians why is this still not
good enough
raise your hand if you know the answer
well nothing it's it's fine as it is so
so any questions like that so make sure
to think it through before because I
think last year's someone was almost
falling out of the chair
right I know I don't know yeah okay this
is fine I mean you can you can build
simulations okay so how do we do the
actual light simulation what I'm
interested in is how much light exits
the surface at the given point so I
think a point in space and the direction
is going to be the direction of my eye
how much is ligh how much light is
coming through from them solution is
obviously the Maxwell equations why
Maxwell equations tell you how
electromagnetic waves behave and light
is an electromagnetic wave in a given
spectrum that is around visible light is
as you heard in the last lecture about
from 400 nanometers to 730 that's that's
more or less than the visible spectrum
well apparently some people are overly
excited about some excellent equations
myself included well I don't have a cool
tattoo like that I I reserved this spot
for the rendering equation
some point let's see about that so
unfortunately this doesn't work
hopefully Thomas have have said some
things about this fad that the basic
principle is that if it's really
nanometers then we would need to have a
simulation on the scale of nanometers
and that's impossible
that's the that's the simple way to put
it and the solution is going to be the
rendering equation and if you would like
a tattoo of an equation I would propose
definitely having the rendering equation
we will see how beautiful it is but at
this point we are not ready to digest
all of it so let's have some theory
before that this is the trivial part
okay so scalar product scalar product is
a number so on the left side I have two
vectors on the right side I have a
number and the scalar product is of a
and B vectors is the length of a time's
the length of B times the cosine of the
angle between the two vectors in this
course if even if I don't say anything
about the length of the vectors a length
of 1 is a soup every almost every single
vector is going to be normalized so if
they are normalized and a length and B
length is 1 so this is strictly going to
be the angle between the two vectors
so the cosines are going to be angles I
mean the cosine of the angle okay some
notation this is what you're going to
see in many of the figures in the
literature what's going on this point of
this is X is the point of interest this
is where we compute some unit and V is
the direction towards the viewer its
flipped on purpose angular fixed
a second so V is a direction towards the
viewer okay so I have this projector
about me the V vector will be pointing
towards me if the XS there the N is the
surface normal L is the vector pointing
towards the light source okay so if I
would be at this point then this L
vector would be two words for instance
that light source or is the reflected
ray direction this means that I have a
point I have a light source life is
coming towards that point and R is where
it's going to be reflected so again an
example there is the projector this is
the point X this is where the light
comes from and this is the reflected
direction so this is flipped along the
surface normal you will see examples of
all of these and theta I and RR incident
and reflected angles and because we are
going to be computing scalar products
and things with vectors it is important
that these vectors that we are talking
about are starting from the same point
so generally in the images you are going
to see this X and some vectors that are
pointing outwards all the time because
these vectors I can use for computations
and just another important thing this is
the definition the mathematical
definition of or this is how you compute
the actual reflected vector but I think
you have you have done this before in
previous courses I think is it the e is
it what the ECG but unfortunately I
don't remember the name but there's some
basic ray tracing is there
shada okay
but even if you haven't seen it you will
see this input and then you will see how
this works okay so let's talk about
light attenuation and with some
experiments let's let's be practical so
the Sun shines on to a point of a
surface from above what portion of the
output of one wave will hit the surface
well this is something like a diffuse
shading so I'm going to compute the dot
product between L and M L is towards the
light vector and is the surface normal
well it seems to me that L and M is the
very same thing
in this scene so this cosine is going to
be zero degrees so the cosine of zero is
one so I'm going to I'm not going to
have any kind of light attenuation in
this case so let's take another example
so the Sun is around here and this is
the light vector and you can also see
the are just just as an example that
this is where it is reflective so I'm
computing this diffuse shading formula
again so L dot n now there is some angle
let's say that this is 45 degrees and a
45 degrees is the cosine of 45 degrees
is 1 over square root of 2 right so the
square root of 2 is 1 point 41 so 1 over
1.4 to 1.0 0.7 so there is some light
and animation if the Sun is located here
and what about the extreme case another
extreme case where it's almost at a 90
degree angle well the cosine of 90
degrees is zero so this means that there
is tons of light attenuation
and this is the reason why it is the the
hottest point of the day blue when the
Sun is exactly above us and after that
it's just it's usually if you don't take
into consideration anything else then
it's only going to get colder and colder
and this is why it's so cold so we can
really model this light attenuation with
a simple dot product which is the cosine
of these vectors